hi I'm fearless I play Nancy Drew and
Nancy Drew in the head staircase and I'm
here at BuzzFeed going to talk to you
about my firsts first embarrassing
moment on a set for the first week of
shooting it we had a rehearsal and we
had to do a lot of getting to know each
other and with the rest of the kids and
we had to do like some acting exercises
a lot of those exercises had to do with
like getting out of your shell doing
some weird trade games and I was so
embarrassed I do not know you people got
purple and kind of embarrassing so
that's that's what I remember with that
I first impression after meeting Amy
Adams I was terrified of meeting Amy
Adams I didn't really hang out with her
a lot because they're kind of playing
the same character I remember one time I
got locked in a room with her for two
whole minutes and I just felt bad
because I had no idea what to say to her
and she had no idea what to say to me so
kind of had like a lot of nodding
involved the nice weather it's okay
hopefully I didn't ruin it first
reaction when you landed the role of
Nancy Drew
it all happened kind of quickly I
remember talking to the director and we
went through the script a little bit
she's really funny it was really fun it
was really fun to do but when I laughed
like after like 20 minutes my mom got a
call saying oh by the way yeah you got
it first celebrity you ever met bill
skarsgård the person to play the clown
it's super tall that's the first thing I
noticed that of him we kind of try to
hide him from us to you know kind of
when we were scared acting scared it's
gonna be Johnny one but I wasn't scared
at all
I mean I kind of tried to hide him but
they're really bad at it so like I
remember I walked in through a door and
he was in this room and he's supposed to
be hidden so but he was in this room
like half make up on and sit
tea or coffee for a straw he kind of
awkwardly said like hey first thing you
do when you're preparing for a role
well I if it's a book or series like
read the book or I try not to watch the
films because I don't want to like
coffee what the other people do but I do
read the books if it's like for instance
Nancy true or it or sharp objects that
was a book so I kind of do that and just
kind of see where my character what my
character is going through and why they
do what they do first time getting
recognized in public oh oh that's hard
oh now I live in New York so a lot of
people do recognize some people do
recognize or even say a lot but a few
people do recognize me but a lot of them
don't do anything they kind of stare at
me and they and I kind of a nod and then
oh I okay I'm just gonna go continue
doing what I'm doing first friend you
made in the industry oh that's hard
because I mean I I worked with all the
all the boys and it and guess
technically they're all my friends so I
guess it's kind of like a first one and
it was kind of all of them my first
friend and was actually on sharp objects
who played my sister her name's Louie
Wilson and we connected really quickly
she was a big ukulele player and we I
bought actually bought a ukulele because
she had a ukulele during Hana Parker
free period we'd get together and we'd
play the ukulele together kind of teach
me I suck I suck so bad on the ecole
Ailee she's great she got even better
she has like a whole collection now she
even has a banjo I miss her
yeah this that's kind of my first friend
in the industry first big red carpet
event I think it was for it yeah that's
right so yeah that was my first big
carpet event oh oh I I am terrified of
those I'm still terrified of those so
I'm just trying to try to remember like
a specific moment in that because all of
them are kind of the same at me kind of
walked down
no idea what to do if her body and some
people go up and talk to you I'm fine
don't get that a good thing I had had
the guys cuz whenever we had a kind of
the interview they were the one who
talked and I kind of nod and sit in the
back and so it was easier for me first
memory of reading or watching Nancy Drew
I definitely heard about Nancy Drew
before the project I never actually like
read the books once my family members
like my aunts and uncles and my friends
heard about this project they gave me
the Nance net a lot of Nancy Drew books
a lot of the first and second ones but
never the third fourth or fifth I had to
buy those myself but now I have a whole
collection of just the first and second
books and there I still have them just
in the corner of my room just a whole
pile first acting gig I guess the first
one that really counts is I used to do a
lot of NYU thesis films before I
actually like acted in like big things
let's see the first one I did was this
very depressing story now looking back
on it was a my mom left me and I was
living with my dad who also worked at a
funeral home not a happy not a happy
story I had fun I had no idea what was
happening throughout but that's normal
for me
[Music]